quick question we will discuss the
rational
and then we're done when do we start
tracing array
well what we did so far is we did the
cutoff so we said
that there's a maximum number of bounces
that i'm going to compute
and the rest of it i'm not interested in
the problem is that this is a bias
solution
and we are missing some energy in the
image because if i would compute many
more subsequent bounces
i would accumulate more radiance so i
will get
perhaps a brighter but a more faithful
image to reality
and we can do much better than that
what's more there is a technique
that can compute an infinite amount of
samples
an infinite amount of depth and and that
bottles the mind a bit because
what is really happening if i would need
to compute
physical reality i would need to have a
maximum depth of infinity i couldn't
even
compute one sample per pixel because i
would have to bounce the array
indefinitely
but there's a mathematical technique
that can give you
the results as if you computed an
infinite number of bonuses
and this is against statistics and
statistics and probability
it's usually very difficult to wrap
one's mind
around what is happening but we can
actually solve this problem
so how can we overcome this
what we're looking for is an estimator
that converges to the expected value of
the integral
and okay that's fine that's fine i'm
looking for the expected value
but having the expected value
or looking for the expected value of
something is one thing but there's not
only
expected value there is variance so i
may have multiple
estimators and what i'm looking for
is one that has the lowest possible
variance
what i can do here is after each step
by step i mean each bounce i decide
whether i will terminate the path so i
would stop
this like that or i would continue
but if i continue i multiply the
collected gradients
with something and the question is what
should be something
now this i would like to relate
to for instance freda's law
in frenet's law we could compute what is
the probability of reflection
and what is the probability of
refraction i hit that glass
window and with some probability
i will continue my rate through the
window and with some other probability i
will get a radiant factor
now what i could do is i could run
many samples and add them together
or what i could also do is that i don't
run many samples
i enter the window and i compute that
there is an 80
chance of reflection and 20 for
refraction
and i will send out only one ray
in each direction but i would multiply
these by the relative probability of the
event
so i'm not tracing 10 000 raised i will
i would send out one
and i would multiply it by 2.8 in one
direction
and 0.2 in another direction and then if
i would do this
yes i would compute more and more
samples but statistically this is sound
so what this means is that this
converges to the expected value of the
integral
and russian roulette does the exact same
thing but
it gives you an infinite number of boxes
so with a given probability i start with
a given probability i continue
but i will multiply the collected
gradients
with a factor and this factor for the
fresnels
example could be the probability of
reflection and reference
what does the algorithm look like i
choose a random variable let's call it
c on zero one and with the given
probability that's bi
i continue the right path after hitting
something every bounce i throw a dice
and if i have this probability i will
continue my right path but i will
multiply the connected radius with
something i won't give you the end
results
as what you would see in the textbook
i'll try to show you
the thought process on how
i will need to multiply it by something
i don't know what this something should
be
we will find out together and if i don't
hit this probability then i will
terminate the right path so we could
imagine this
as if i continued the light path but i
multiplied
all the subsequent gradients by zero
i spoiled the zero for the second
question mark so damn it but
you would you would have found this out
in a second anyway
okay so i'm looking for the expected
value of something
l i the hat means an estimation an
estimator
and on the right side this is the actual
error so whatever happens in the middle
is some magic but the constraint is that
the expected value of the estimator
should be the same as the original
quantity that i'm looking for
there's a probability of continuation
and
if i don't hit this probability then i
will stop the stopping part is trivial
if i stop then i will multiply this term
with zero so imagine that i continue my
line path i won't because it's wasted
time
until infinity but it's multiplied by
zero
now the question is what is the other
question mark
what i know is that on the right side
i would want to get l i so forget this
right term
what do i need to do with this
expression on the left
in order to get l i on the right side
raise your hand if you know the answer i
think i wanted to
i want you to take a few seconds and
think about it
what do i need to do to get l i
from this expression the rest is
multiplied by zero so this doesn't
matter
raise your hand if not
okay maybe maybe
okay yes please first
okay uh i think is
yes okay
so i kill the pi because i don't see any
pi here
so there's gonna be a fraction and the
denominator
is going to be pi so i killed this guy
but there's no one in there
and i want someone in there and that
someone is the li
so i kill the pi with my fraction and
in the numerator there is going to be l
so if i do
this then what i am doing is going to be
statistically sound and i'll try to give
you the intuition again
this takes time to wrap your head around
it is almost like
in the fret out equation that what you
could do
is you could send out one ray
in one direction so you can send out
800 rays in one direction and sum them
up
what you could do is that i send out
only one ray
and i multiply it with 800
and no i would not get the same result
but i will get the same expected value
and over time the variance around this
expected value would shrink if i do this
many times
so this is the intuition behind the
whole thing
what is a good choice for the pi because
this has been a parameter so far what
should i put
in there well
with a little scratch i could say it
doesn't matter you could
put many sensible choices in there and
it would work
but quickly let's review the cases where
it would not work well obviously
the two very stupid options if you put
p i equals zero then this would mean
that you would never continue your path
you would always stop
so this is obviously correct what if i
say pi
equals one but this means that i would
always continue i would never stop
well you could say mathematically this
is sound but you could never compute one
sample per pixel
if you're a mathematician you would say
i have a turing machine that would never
stop
it doesn't make too much sense if you're
looking for a practical solution
now anything in between the two is
completely fine
the only difference is because i i i've
showed you
that the expected value is
the same as the actual quantity done
that i'm looking for
but the variance is different so it is
oscillating around
the very same number but the magnitude
of the oscillation
depends on this choice
and what you can prove but it is
actually very easy to
visualize that the good choice for the
pi would usually be
something that would sample brighter
paths longer
and darker paths i would want to
terminate faster
because this is the same as matching the
green function with the
the blue function with the green bars i
want to reconstruct the brighter regions
more faithfully than darker regions
because this is what gives me the
smaller error so what you can plug in in
there
is for instance the albedo of the
material so if you have a really bright
white wall then you would with a super
high probability you will want to
continue your power
but if you have really if you encounter
a really dark object like the curtains
in the other side of the room
you would want to stop with a much
larger probability so this is how
russian roulette works we will also code
this so in the next lecture you will see
the the whole thing that we've studied
in code